دعت وزيره خارجيه الالمانيه ان لينا بربوك
الصين الى مطالبه من سمته المعتديه الروسي
بوقف حربه في اوكرانيا وبشان قضيه تايوان
حذرت بربوك في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيرها
الصيني في بجينه من استخدام القوه لتغيير
الوضع في شبه الجزيره وتاتي زياره الوزيره
الالمانيه الى الصين بعد ايام من زياره
الرئيس الفرنسي لها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تتالي زيارات
الاوروبيه الى الصين في هذا التوقيت وكيف
يمكن ان ينظر الى تزاملها مع ارتفاع حده
التوتر بين واشنطن وبجينا وما مدى اتساق
المواقف التي عبرت عنها وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه في بجين
مع المواقف التي سبقها اليها ماكرون وما
محددات رؤيه اوروبا لقضيه تايوان وعلى اي
نحو تنظر الولايات المتحده لزياره
المسؤولين الاوروبيين الى بيجين وما فرص
تاثير هذه الزيارات على سياسه الصين من
وجهه النظر الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
بعد اقل من اسبوع فقط من مغادره الرئيس
الفرنسي الاراضي الصينيه في زياره دوله
استمرت ثلاثه ايام حطت في بجين وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا في زياره بدا
من خلالها بدا من خلال تصريحاتها في
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك مع نظيرها الصيني
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا وقضيه تايوان هي
ابرز دواعي هذه الزياره
الصين الى مطالبه ما سمته المعتديه الروسي
بوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا واكدت انه لا توجد
دوله اخرى لها تاثير على روسيا اكثر من
الصين اما في قضيه تايوان فقد حذرت
الوزيره الالمانيه من استخدام القوه
لتغيير الوضع هناك وقالت ان ذلك سيكون
سيناريو كارثيا للعالم باسره وانه لن يكون
مقبولا لدى الاوروبيين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من برلين السفير
جونسون مولاك الدبلوماسي السابق ومدير
المعهد الالماني لدراسات الشرقيه وينضم
الينا منا ميرلاند بالولايات المتحده
تشارلزون عضو مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق نرحب بكما سيد
ملاك وسيد شارلز كابتشينو في برلين السفير
جونتورمولاك عفوا
هذه الزيارات الاوروبيه المتتاليه زياره
الرئيس ايمن الفرنسي ايميل ماكرون الى
بيجين ثم بعد ذلك زياره وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ماذا وراء هذا التتابع وهذا
التتالي لزيارات الاوروبيه الى بجين
بالنسبه لوزيره
خارجيتنا السيده هذه هي الزياره الرسميه
الاولى لها بصفتها وزيره خارجيه المانيا
الى الصين وستستمر ايضا برحلتها الى كوريا
الجنوبيه وفي اليابان ايضا بالتالي هو امر
طبيعي لكن اصبح
اهميه لانه اتى على اعقاب زياره الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون والذي كان يحاول ان يرضي
الصين عن طريق القول اننا لا تتبع
الولايات المتحده دائما
واعتقد ان الامر لم يكن جيدا لم يكن
دبلوماسيا ولم يكن صحيحا من الناحيه من
ناحيه الصياغه اعتقد ان معظم الاوروبيين
ومعظم الناس هنا في المانيا لم يكونوا
راضينا عن الخطاب وتصريحات الرئيس ماكرون
لكن علينا ان نتذكر ايضا ان الفرنسيين
دائما كان لديهم مشاكل مع الولايات
المتحده كل الرؤساء دائما حاولوا ان
يظهروا انهم يتمتعون باستقلاليه معه وانهم
لا يخضعوا لتاثير الامريكيين والى اخره
بالتالي الزياره لم تكن جيده بالتالي
وزيره الخارجيه كانت تحاول ان
تغطي ربما وتملا ايه ثغرات قد اعترت الجهد
الدبلوماسي وايضا كانت تتبع ما قالته
السيده فنجر لاين
الاتحاد الاوروبي ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه وما قالته انها كانت كانت واضحه
وصارمه في وجهات نظرها وتحدثت عن كل شيء
بامكاننا ان نتخيله ايضا كان هنالك طلب
وحث للصين لايقافي الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بالتاكيد على عدم ارسالي اسلحه
ايضا الى روسيا
وليس هنالك حل عسكري لاسراء وايضا وزيره
الخارجيه كان وزير الخارجيه كان هنالك رفض
انتقاد رئيس وزير الخارجيه الصينيه رفض
الانتقاد متعلق بحقوق الانسان ولم يعترف
ان هنالك ربما معايير واحده تم وضعها من
قبل الاعلان العالمي لحقوق الانسان لكن مع
ذلك كان هنالك مناقشات ط اجرها مع بعضهم
البعض عندما كانوا
علمتني القطار ولن اصفها بالنقاشات السيئه
قالت وزيره الخارجيه عندما يتحسن وضع حقوق
الانسان وعندما تظل الامور سلميه الامر
افضل لاجراء النقاشات ولعقد الصفقات بين
البدين انت تقول المحادثات لا تصفها بانها
سيئه وهذا يعني انها جيده اذا كانت جيده
بالنسبه للاوروبيين وهنا اتحول الى السيد
تشارلز في ميريلاند اذا كان الامر هكذا
بالنسبه للاوروبيين ما الذي يمنع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تفعل نفس الشيء
ولماذا لا نرى نفس المساعي اذا من جانب
المسؤولين الامريكيين
انا اتفق مع زميلي في المانيا
يشعرون بقلق مشروع بعنوان قد يكون كمفصام
لاحقا وربما الولايات المتحده قد تضغط
عليهم اكثر او انها تسرع بشكل اكثر من
اللازم نحو التوجه نحو حرب بارد جديده مع
الصين ولا شك ان الوضع السياسي الداخلي
هنا في الولايات المتحده وكذلك الوضع
السياسي الداخلي في الصين حيث ان يشجل
بدءا ولايته الثالثه ويعزز قبضته على على
الاخرين وبالتالي ربما الافضل ان نقول
لنهدا قليلا ونحاول ان نبني علاقه اكثر
بناءه بين الغرب ككل والصين
ملاك لاحظنا ان زياره الرئيس الفرنسي
ترافقت مع زياره رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسلها
فندر لاين وقد اشرت الى ذلك قبل قليل
وايضا هذه المره زياره وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ايضا تاتي مع زياره جوزيف بوريل
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
هل من دلاله برايك
لمرافقه مسؤولين على مستوى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لهذين المسؤولين الفرنسي
والالماني الى بجين
نعم
اعتقد اننا الان هي تحدثنا عن زياره وزيره
الخارجيه الاولى
للصين وبسبب موقفي وزياره الرئيس ماكرون
الى
اظهار ان الموقف الاوروبي مختلف بالتالي
هي كانت على نفسي الخط الذي كانت عليه
سيده فونجرلاين وقالت ان وضع حقوق الانسان
في الصين ليس بالجيد وان اي سياسات عدائيه
ضد تايوان هي لا نرى ليست مرحب بها ولا
نرى طريقه للحل العسكريه او للحلول
العسكريه من اجل ان تكون الصين لها دور في
تايوان لكنها حاولت ان تمررها بطريقه تبدو
لطيفه نوعا ما وقالت انه اذا ما كان هنالك
سلام في المنطقه اعتقد ان تعاوننا
واستثماراتنا وشركاتنا سيكونون اكثر امانا
وسي بحال ومناخ افضل من اجل عقد الصفقات
التجاريه بالتالي هي قامت بزيارته ايضا
بعض الشركات التجاريه الالمانيه التي تعمل
في الصين وتحدثت ايضا عن مشاكل التلوث
المناخي والبيئه الذي يمكن القيام به
بالتالي هي كما قلت
حاولت القول اننا لسنا بالاعداء ولكننا
لسنا اصدقاء مقربين نحن لسنا اعداء لكن
بامكاننا ان نعقد صفقات تجاريه بين الصين
وبين الجانب الاوروبي روان التصرف بطريقه
متحضره وان لا يكون هنالك من قبل الصين
لاي تدخل عسكري في تايوان الشيء المثير
للاهتمام انه كان هنالك شركات عفوا جزر
صغيره تبعد عن ثلاث كيلومترات من الاراضي
الرئيسيه للصين وهي تتبعه تايوان مكانه
هنالك وهي تتمتع بسلام كان هنالك ايضا
مثلا الزيارات لشراء بضائع معينه وايضا
كان هنالك ربما تحد حديث عن وحده عسكريه
صغيره لكن هذا الامر يظهر ان هذا الامر ان
هذا الوضع بامكانه ان ينجح بامكان كل هذه
العوامل ان تعمل مع بعضها البعض بشكل ناجح
لكن دائما هذا الامر باتهامي التايوان
والانفصاليين كل ما حصل شيء يقومون تقوم
الصين بارسال قواتها البحريه هذه ليست
الطريقه التي يمكن ان يتم ايجاد بها
الحلول نعم طيب سيد تشارلز عندما يقول
جونتر ملاك انه الرساله من وراء هذه
الزيارات هو ان نقول لبيجين نحن لسنا
اعداء لسنا اصدقاء ولكن لسنا اعداء ايضا
اليس في ذلك ربما طريقه يحاول بها
الاوروبيون
التنصل او ربما تلمس طريق من الخروج من
الازمه الاوكرانيه وا زمه الحرب على
اوكرانيا التي دفع فيها الاوروبيون ثمنا
باهضا اكثر من الامريكيين بكثير
فكره ان لا نكون اعداء ولا نكون اصدقاء هو
المفهوم الصحيح هذه علاقه تتطور وان الصين
تتوجه نحو ان تصبح اكثر قدره من الناحيه
العسكريه والاقتصاديه ولكن مازلنا في
بدايه هذه القصه وبالتالي يعتقد فعلا ان
الجانبين عليهما ان يبقى مفتوحين الفكري
والعلاقات فيما يتعاملون فيه واتفق مع ما
موجود في سؤالك بان حاليا هناك دور مهم
يمكن ان تلعبه الصين لتطوير الاستقرار
العالمي والسلام العالمي ويكون ذلك بوضع
الضغوط على
حربه في اوكرانيا لان هذه فعلا هي حرب
تخلب استقرار ليس فقط استقرار اوروبا بل
العالم كله وصحه طاقه صحه في الغذاء وهناك
استقطار للن العالمي وبدعه للاسف بيجي لا
يبدو انها مستعده للتحرك في نحو هذا
الطريق وشاهدنا ان السيد في موسكو قبل
اسابيع وهو لم يقل للسيد فتن ان ينهي
الحرب بل هو تراجع عن ضعف دعمه للسيد
فوتين حاليا ان مع الاسف نحن في موقفين
نجد ان الصين ليسوا مستعدين بان يختلفوا
مع روسيا حول حرب لكن في نهايه هذه السنه
اذا ما وصلت لعمليات العسكريه حاله ركود
ربما يحصل ذلك ولكن المعنى نحن لا نصل الى
هذه المرحله لكن لماذا لا يكون الموضوع هو
يعني زيارات بالتنسيق مع الجانب الامريكي
وكانه توزيع ادوار بين طرفين
انا فعلا اعتقد ان هناك ما يمكن اسميه
توزيع العمل حيث ان الولايات المتحده تتخذ
موقف اكثر شده من اوروبا وربما تتعب دوري
الشرطي الطيب
وايضا ذلك اعتقد انه من مهم جدا انه
اوروبا والولايات المتحده ان يقدمها جبهه
متحده بحيث يتوضح للصين بانها لا يمكن
تلعب العاب وتحاول ان تحرك الولايات
المتحده الاوروبيين وبالعكس في جمع حوالي
اعتقد ان هذا البرنامج لا يعتقد انه سينجح
واتفق مع السفير بان السيد لوحده عندما
يدعو الى استقلال استراتيجين اوروبي
وعندما يقول ان العرفه لازم تقبل التابعه
للولايات المتحده هذا خطاب وان يعود الى
التاريخ الفرنسي الى ايام
ورغبته في ابعاد خروج فرنسا جناح العسكري
للنيتو وهذا ليس كالخطاب الذي يتمتع باي
شعبيه في اوروبا وخاصه في المانيا التي تم
بالتاكيد ملتزمه بقوه العلاقات على
المداعيد بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده
يعني الى اي يعني حد يمكن ان يكون الموقف
الالماني
متناسقا او متحدا مع الموقف في الفرنسي في
ان اوروبا لا يجب ان تكون تابعه للولايات
المتحده في سياستها الخارجيه
اتجاه تايوان نتحدث هنا عن القضيه
التايوانيه
اننا باستطاعتنا ان
نقوم باقناعي زملائنا واصدقائنا الفرنسيين
في ايجاد خط واحد مشترك مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي فيما يتعلق
بما قمنا به في سياساتنا الخارجيه
وعلاقاتنا مع الصين لكن ماكرون لديه ربما
ربما نمط مختلف هو يحاول ان يتغلب على
بلده الان هو هو
مستشارنا السيد شورس لسوء الحظ هو لما
يولد كقائد يتحدث بشكل واضح لكن نامل اننا
سنتفق وسيكون لنا موقف موحد ربما في
المره القادمه او في الاجتماع المقبل
لرؤساء وزراء الاتحاد الاوروبي ونقوم
بمناقشه كل لانني اعتقد انما حصل مؤسف لكن
ماكرون اجرى صفقات جيده هو كان له وفد
كبير مع رؤساء مدراء تنفيذيين وعقد صفقات
تجاريه جيده مع الصين والتي ربما هي كانت
احد الاسباب التي لم
تدفعه لكي يكون صارما جدا مع الصين وكما
ذكر زميلي الامريكي هذه هي الطريقه
الفرنسيه منذ عهده منذ عهد ونحن معتادون
عليها وعلينا ان نتحد في موقف واحد هذا
الامر في غايه الاهم علينا ان نتحدث في
موقف واحد دعني انقل هذه الفكره لسيد
شارلز
الاوروبيون متحدون على موقف واحد هل هذا
برايك يزعج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
يكون للاوروبيين موقف خاص بهم من قضيه
تايوان يتصق مع مصالح الدول الاوروبيه
وليس بالضروره مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
اعتقد ان
ان في التوازن تتمنى ان اوروبا تتماسك
فيهم بينها وان تتولى مسؤوليات اكبر على
الصعيد العالمي ولكن كشريك للولايات
المتحده وليس
ثقل موازي او منافس ولايه متحده كما يبدو
ان السيد مكرونه يقترح ذلك احيانا ولكن قد
هناك اختلاف في الاراء حول تايوان وهو انه
الولايات المتحده لديها مصلحه اكبر كثير
في هذا المجال فالقوات الامريكيه موجوده
في كوريا الجنوبيه في اليابان وفي الفلبين
وعاده البارجات الحربيه الامريكيه هي التي
في مضيقه تايوان وليس السفن الالمانيه اما
لفرنسا فلدها وجود وحدي بسيط في محيط
الهادي
وبالتالي هذا يعني ان الولايات المتحده هي
الدوله التي ستتقدم اذا حاجه للدفاع عن
تايوان ضد اي عدوان الصين ولكن نهايه
المطاف لا اعتقد ان الاوروبيين رايا
مختلفا فيما يتعلق بتايوان ولكن ربما هم
ياخذون الموقعه الخلفي مع بالنسبه المتحده
لانه ليس اللاعبين الكبار العسكريا في
المنطقه مره اخرى كنا اختلاف الاراء هذا
اللي ظهرناه وهذا الاسبوع اعتقد في رايته
نتركه وراءنا وننساه الفكره واضحه
نعم سؤال اخير للسيد جونسون ملاك هل تعتقد
ان الاوروبيين قادرون فعلا على التاثير
على السياسه الصينيه تحديدا في موضوع
اوكرانيا وتايوان
لقد حاولنا بدله ما بوسعنا هي الصين بلد
كبير لكنهم يحتاجون جزءا من تكنولوجيتين
ويحتاجون الى الاستثمارات ايضا التي والتي
نقوم بها وخاصه في مجال
الطاقه الخضراء والمجالات الاخرى اذا ما
اردنا ان نتعاون على الاقل كشركاء اذا ما
قلنا في هذه في هذه المجالات علينا ايضا
ان نكون قادرين على ان نثق بقياده الصين
وان نستمر
ربما باجراء نوع من
الحديث عن السياسات السلميه مع تايوان لا
نقوم نحطهم على عدم ارسال قواتهم العسكريه
والتهديد باجراء خطوات عسكريه او اجراءات
عسكريه بالتالي نحن قوه
روسيا ليست بشيء علينا ان نعترف بهذا
الامر كقوه اقتصاديه روسيا ليس لديها اي
قوه روسيا ستحتاج الى الصين وهذا هو امر
واضح للغايه لانهم سيحتاجون الى اسلحه
وامور اخرى من الصين لكن على الاقل هذا
شيء جيد باستطاعته وقد وحد وزير الخارجيه
الصيني بعدم ارسال اسلحه الى روسيا وهذا
قد يتم استخدامها في الصراع في اوكرانيا
بالتالي انا اتابع هذا الامر وانا لست
متشائما لكن هنالك شيء في غايه الوضوح
علينا ان ان نعمل سويه يدا بيد مع
الولايات المتحده وهو وهي قوه ضخمه عسكريه
ما الذي نستطيع ان نقوم به بالمدمرات او
بعض الغواصات المنتشره هناك نحن لسنا
قادرين حقا على اننا نحدث فقرا على
المقاطعه انتهى وقت البرنامج شكرا
وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]